[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
شقق
تابعه للحرس الثوري تلمح الاعدام عشره
المتظاهرين
قمم الرياض تفتح النوافذ لمنفعه المتبادله
وشراكه استراتيجيه شامله بين العرب
بصحه السعوديه تقول ان نشاطا الانفلونزا
الموسميه هذا العام اقوى من السنوات
الماضيه
في الرابعه
فريق بحثي بهيئه المساحه الجيولوجيه
السعوديه يكشف احافير نادره يتجاوز عمرها
600000 سنه
والجماهير العربيه تتركب انطلاق المواجهه
بين اسود الاطلس ومنتخب البرتغال بقياده
رونالدو
نبدا من ايران حيث المحت صحيفه تابعه
للحرس الثوري الايراني
الاخير واضافت بان هناك احتمالات لاعدام
اكثر من 60 محتجا اخرين خلال الايام
المقبله ودانت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه تنفيذ حكم الاعدام في شكاره
مؤكده بانها تمت وفقا لمحاكمه سوريا ولم
تخضع لاي اجراءات القانونيه
تريدات الحرس الثوري يقابلها اتساع في
موجه الدعوات للاحتجاجات ضد النظام
الايراني في مناطق مختلفه من البلاد بعد
اعدام المتظاهر محسن شكاري وبالتزامن مع
اليوم العالمي لحقوق الانسان قد دعت
مجموعه شباب احياء طهران المواطنين الى
القيام بمسيره احتجاجيه من ساحه توحيد الى
ساحه الصادقيه في طهران وطالبت مجموعه
شباب احياء كرج اهالي المدينه بعدم القيام
باي عمليات شراء او معاملات بنكيه وطلبت
مجموعه شباب احيائها مدان من الاهالي ايضا
النزول الى الشوارع للتعبير عن الغضب من
اعدام محسن شكري فما دعت مؤسسه تسمى تعزيز
المجتمع المنفتح دعت الناس من جميع انحاء
العالم الى التضامن مع الانتفاضه الشعبيه
في ايران
بان عشره مؤسسات و30 مدينه دعمت هذه
الدعوه حتى الان
اداره مقاطع فيديو منشوره على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وقوع حريق النهائي في
سكنه سكنه امام حسين للحرس الثوري والبسيج
داخل مدينه الاهواز
ومن الاحتجاجات التي تعم ايران الى
الانشقاقات التي تتسع داخل عائله خامني
حيث قضت محكمته رجال الدين الخاصه بايران
على فريده مرت خالي ابنتي اقتل مرشد
الايراني
ثلاث سنوات بعد التماسها من النيابه وذلك
عقاب لها على الدعوه لطرد سفراء ايران
دعما للاحتجاجات في بلادها
محمد حسين قاسي محامي ابنه شقيقه المرشد
في تغريده على على تويتر بانه تم قبول
الاستئناف على الحكم وتاكيده بالسجن لمده
ثلاث سنوات محامي فريده مراد خانك كشف بان
موكله حكمت في محكمه رجال الدين الخاصه
رغم ان هذه المحكمه ليس من اختصاصها النظر
في تهامي فريده
الى تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث قال رئيس
الاوكراني فلاديمي الوضع في المناطق
الرئيسيه لجبهه الدوم بس في شرق اوكرانيا
لا يزال صعبا للغايه مشيرا الى ان القوات
بلاده تصد الهجمات الروسيه وتتسبب في
خسائر كبيره
من اي اجزاء سليمه
لقد دمر المحتلون عمليا
الجيش الروسي الى انقاضى اشكر جميع
ابطالنا جميع الجنود والقاده الذين
يسيطرون على الجبهه في هذه المناطق ويصدون
الهجمات ويلحقون خسائر ملحوظه بالعدو ردا
على الجحيم الذي دخل اوكرانيا تحت العالم
الروسي
وزير الخارج
الى مسار العمليات العسكريه ضد روسيا
وكاله في تصريحات صحفيين ضربات الروسيه
تتدمرت اكثر من نصف محطات الكهرباء في
البلاد تدميرا كاملا وطالبه كوليبالي
مجتمع الدوليه على روسيا على رامي
القانوني الدولي
المقابله اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استمرار العمليات العسكريه في عده محاور
خاصه في دمياتك ولمن واجبار القوات
الاوكرانيه على تركيب واقعها وقالت
الوزاره في بيانها اليومي ان قواتها اسقطت
اربع طائرات بدون طيار اوكرانيه في
دانياتك وعشر قذائف من طرازهم مارس في
زبوند واضافت بانها دمرت رادار الامريكيه
مضاد للصواريخ في منطقه سكاي
يختمت بالامس اعماله قمم الرياضه الثلاثه
بالتاكيد على تعزيز الشركات الاستراتيجيه
بين الدول العربيه والصين وذلك بما يقوم
على مبادئ التعاون الشامل والمشترك في
مختلف المجالات بالاضافه الى دعم الجهود
الراميه الى منع انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
وفقا لمعاهده عدم انتشار الاسلحه النوويه
ام بي تي مع التاكيد على اخلاء منطقه
الشرق الاوسط من اسلحه الدمار الشامل كما
جاء في البيان الختامي لنتائج القمه
العربيه الصينيه تاكيدات تدعو الى اهميه
تضافر الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه لايجاد
حلول سياسيه الى الازمات في سوريا وليبيا
واليمن مع رفض التدخلات الاجنبيه في هذه
الدول
قطاعه جديده واعده ثلاث قمم احتضنتها
الرياض في حراك الدبلوماسيه يهدف الى
اعاده التوازن اليوستراتيجي للمنطقه من
خلال فتح نوافذ لتحقيق شراكه خليجيه عربيه
مع الصين مستقله وقائمه على المصالح
المشتركه
القمم الثلاث السعوديه الصينيه والخليجيه
الصينيه والعربيه الصينيه انتهت بنتائج
اكدت على اهميه تعزيز التعاون والحوار
المشترك بين السعوديه والصين والخليج
والدول العربيه
وتصدرتها قضايا الامن والاقتصاد بالمنطقها
ابرز مركزت عليه البيانات الختاميه للقمم
الثلاث مواجهه التحديات العالميه وضمان
الطابع السلمي للبرنامج النووي الايراني
وكذلك اداله الهجمات الحوثيه على الاهداف
المدنيه في السعوديه والامارات بالاضافه
الى التمسك بمفاهيم الامن مشترك من نوع
وصفت بالحدث المفصلي في تاريخ العلاقات
الصينيه العربيه فيما اعتبر محللون ان
التعاون العربي الصيني لن يكون على حساب
التعاون مع امريكا لان التعاون مع بكين
يركز بشكل كبير على الجوانب الاقتصاديه
والتكنولوجيه والتنميه
وهذا بعيد عما تتشاركه الدول العربيه
وهذا بعيد عما تتشاركه الدول العربيه مع
الولايات المتحده في ما يتعلق بالجوانب
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه في الشرق الاوسط
كما انه يعرف عجبا كبير
الاعلام الاردنيه السابق سيد سميح مرحبا
بك معي في نشره الرابعه من اولا
هل تتفق مع الراي القائل بان هذه القمه
اتحدث عن القمه العربيه الصينيه تؤسس
فعليا لمرحله جديده في علاقات استراتيجيه
بين الدول العربيه والصين
العلاقات العربيه الصينيه لها تاريخ طويل
اول علاقه كما تعلم حضرتك دبلوماسيه بين
دوله عربيه هي مصر والصين كانت سنه 56 ثم
تدرجت او بدات يعني بقيه العلاقات من ذلك
الوقت الى اليوم وفي علاقات قويه سابقا
مكرره بين الدول العربيه كلنا على حدا مع
الصين اليوم هذه القمم بقى هذا باعتقد هذا
النهج بالقياده السعوديه اللي هو تاسيس
العلاقات مع القوه الكبرى على اساس وعلى
اتفاقيات وعلى مسارات واضحه بمعنى تبني
على المكان هو كان شيء مهم في العلاقات في
مجالات مختلفه كان في تجارب ايضا بالمواقف
السياسيه من الازمات المنطقه
الملف الفلسطيني الملف السوري مع الصين
لديها يعني انحيازات في موضوع الملف
السوري لكن في مواقف عامه في اشتراك فيها
لكن هذا الامر باعتقد انه سياسيا بكسر
الاحتكار الامريكي للمنطقه بمعنى انه صحيح
كان في علاقات اليوم انت كدول العربيه دول
خليجيه السعوديه بثقالها السياسي
والاقتصادي هي كمان تبني هذه العلاقات
وتعطي مساحات واسعه وواضحه للعلاقات مع
الصين بشكل اساسي والصين كما تعلم بتتذكر
حضرتك بعيد لما كان في في جده قبل سته
شهور كان يقول انه الانسحاب الامريكي او
خروج امريكا من المنطقه بشكل ما اعطى
مساحات اضافيه لروسيا والصين يعني امريكا
لا تريد ان تعطي هذه المساحات للدول
المنافسه لها سياسيه واقتصاديا هما الصين
وروسيا لكن هذا يعني ليس ملزم للدول
المنطقه اليوم في خطين متوازيين بعد قمه
امس في خط العلاقه الاستراتيجيه مع
الولايات المتحده والتحالفات بمسارات
مختلفه العلاقه مع عصير ليست بمدير
بالتاكيد وليست نوع من المناكفه للعلاقه
بعد اميركان لكن تعطي مساحه جيده ومساحه
لماذا لماذا
لا يمكن ان تسبب سوء فهم مع الامريكان
الامريكان كانوا وضحين هنا يقول الكثير
بان بعيد جاء وقال اننا لن نترك فراغ لكن
ما حدث يدل فعلا على ان هناك استغلال من
قبل الصين الان لهذه الحاله ربما من
الانسحاب الامريكي او من الفراغ الامريكي
فبالتالي هل ستقبل دوله الولايات المتحده
تعتبر هذه المنطقه منطقه نفوذ لها ان تذهب
بعيدا في علاقتها مع عدو لها الان يعني
تتشابك معه في في صراع عالميه يعني في في
همم على في النظام الدولي
لا انا الحقيقه بقول انه المنطقه العربي
لا يريد ان يضحي بالعلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده هذا راي العرب لا يريده لكن
الامريكان بالتاكيد سيكون منزعجين جدا من
هذا التوسع بالمساحات التي تعطى للعلاقه
مع الصين وايضا بالمساحات الموجوده
بالعلاقه مع روسيا لانه الصين دوله ااه
تتسلل بنعومه في العالم عبر الاقتصاد
وتتسلم بالعمى بصناعتها باستثماراتها
بعلاقاتها وهذا امر يزعج الامريكان كثيرا
الامريكان في بعض الدول كانوا منزعجين من
بعض المشاريع وليس من علاقات بهذا الحجر
كما قلت انه اذا اذا اذا اذا اذا اذا
الدول العربيه في علاقات اكثر همم مع
الصين هل سيجعل ذلك همم العمل مع الولايات
المتحده يصل عند عتب معينه اكثر صعوبه
في بعض الملفات الولايات المتحده ستقاتل
من اجل افشال اشك بعض اشكال التعاون
العربي او الخليجي مع الصين هذا واضح يعني
سيكون هناك نوع من الضغوطات الامريكيه على
دول عربيه على الاط- على ايطار هي
تستطيعوه لابشال بعض المشاريع بعض اشكال
التعاون يعني الولايات المتحده لن تمرر
هذا الموضوع بسهوله لكنه ليس يعني هذا
الاطار الذي تقوده المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بعتقد انه جاء ضمن سياق السياسه
السعوديه اللي هي ب 2022 كانت اكثر تجاليا
في العمل انه الولايات المتحده التي كانت
تتعامل بنوع من خليني اقول التحريض على
على السعوديه كانت تتعامل بشكل سلبي مع
السعوديه لكن بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه
الروسيه تغيرت الموازين القوات الحاجات
تغيرت وكنا جميعا نراقب قمه تجدد قبل ست
شهور وكيف اضطرت امريكا الى ان تاتي الى
السعوديه تقدم طلبات لم يستجاب للكثير
منها واضطرت لان تتنازل عن كثير من التي
كانت تحرض بها على السعوديه وان تغلق بعض
الملفات التي كان البعض في الاداره
الديمقراطيه وحرض بها السعوديه هذا انجاز
باعتقد للسياسه السعوديه والقياده
السعوديه والخليجيه انها اخذت امريكا الى
المساحه التي تريدها هي ثم لم تكتفي لان
الامريكان لما يجوا على جده بشهر سته لم
يخرجوا بكامل ما يريده يعني موضوع النفط
زياده الانتاج النفط لم يحصلوا على مكان
يريد او ملفات اخرى اليوم في خطوه اضافيه
باقول بيعطاء اهميه للدور العربي او
للحركه العربي والقياده السعوديه انه
انتجت بالعربي الصين وجيت واعطيت نفس
الشكل الذي ثلاث قمم همم خليجيه وسعوديه
وعربيه واعطيت المساحات باتفاقات اوسع مع
الصين تحدثت معها في ملفات مهمه هم
المنطقه بشكل اساسي هذا بالتاكيد لانه
يعجب الامريكان ولم يكونوا مرتاحين ولن
وسيحاول يقدر ما يستطيعوا ان يفصلوا بما
استطاعوا من هذه التفاهمات
لكن هذا القرار سيكون في النهايه للصين
ولا ولا العرب بشكل عام القمه السعودي
يمكن كان اوضح في همم يعني استراتيجيات
العلاقه خلال فتره القادمه هناك تعاون
هناك شراكه على اكثر من مجال يعني في
مجالات متعدده يعني لكن ماذا عن بيان
القمه العربيه الصينيه الى اي مدى بالفعل
هناك انسجام واضح من الدول العربيه في
طريقه استراتيجيه او مستقبل العلاقه مع
الصين اي ماده هناك استجاب بين البيانين
يا دكتور سمير
يعني شوف لما بتحكي عن بيان عربي بتحكي عن
مجموعه من الدول كل كل دوله لديها حدود
للتعامل الاقتصادي مع مع الصين يعني
السعوديه
بتكوين الاقتصادي بقدرات الاقتصاديه غير
عن دوله اكس دوله واي في ال في العلاقات
يعني بالامكانات وباشكال التعاون لكن ما
بعتقد انه في رغبه عند العرب بالتعامل مع
الصين اقتصاديا وفي جهد يعني الصين موجوده
بالسودان كانت قديما باستثمارات موضوع
النفط موجوده بدول عربيه اخرى لكن انت
عندما تتحدث عن مجموعه من الدول لها همم
يعني قدرات متباينه ولديها همم يعني خلينا
نقول تحديات داخليه مختلفه لا تستطيع غير
لما بتتحدث عن دوله واحده تتحدث بمتماسك
اقتصاديه متماسكه سياسيه تقول قيادتها
انها ستذهب في علاقه ثنائيه مع الصين بهذا
الشكل هو طبيعه البيانات الجماعيه دائما
لا تكون مثل البيانات الثنائيه لكن تقدير
انه العرب لديهم رغبه لكن بعض الدول هي
تدرك يا خلينا نكون ايضا واضحين انها يعني
ان الولايات المتحده ستبدا العمل سريعا
همم بعد بعد انتهاء القمم اللي كان انتهاء
امس ستبدا العمل سريعا لوضع فرامل او كبح
جماح اي تعاون سي او اي تمدد صيني
بالمنطقه يزيد عنه هو موجود الان في القصه
ليست سهله لكن عمليا انت تكسر احتكار
الامريكان للمنطقه همم وهذا امر خطوه
سياسيه مهمه سياسيا بالتوازن السياسي
للدول الكبرى ولل اقطاب العالم السياسيه
والاقتصاديه انت تعمل توازن اكثر يعني انا
استقرارا في من ظل القمم ما بين قمه جده
شهر سته وما بين قمه الرياض اللي هي اللي
كانت امس وهو اول امس شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه الافاده من عمان سميح المعايطه وزير
الاعلام الاردني نساء
في الرابعه بعد قليل
اسبوع واحد ضبط القرابه 15 الف مخالف
لانظمه الاقامه والعمل في السعوديه
اي نوع الم اول شكوى
للحين ما تلاقي اللي يحررك منه
بس هذيك اللحظه اللي بتبدا تشعر فيها انك
اخيرا بتتحرر منا هي نفس اللحظه اللي
بتشعر فيها انك رجعت الى طبيعتك زي في اي
يوم طبيعي
[موسيقى]
ايش ما كان نوع المك
التحرر من الالم يبدا بباندول
[موسيقى]
اربطوا الاحزمه واسترخو هذه رحله الى عالم
اخر سنمزجه جدا
[موسيقى]
نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره الكامله
الجمعه والسبت الثامنه على شاشه العربيه
معجون سنسداين المطور ترميمه حمايه الجديد
بيدخل لعمق السن وهذا بيساعد فانه يقلل من
حساسيه الاسنان امسح الاشخاص انهم ما
يهملوا مشكله حساسيه الاسنان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلانات وزاره الداخليه
السعوديه ضبطها اكثر من 14 الف مخالف
لانظمه الاقامه والعمل ومن الحدود في
مختلف المناطق البلاد بالاضافه الى منعها
438 شخصا حاولوا عبور الحدود الى السعوديه
بطرق غير نظاميه وكشفت الداخليه السعوديه
بانها قامت بتنفيذ الانظمه بحق المخالفين
من خلال الترحيلها اكثر من احد 10,000
شخصا خلال اسبوع
اكيد المتحدثه باسم وزاره الصحه السعوديه
الدكتور محمد عبد العال بان الانفلونزا
الموسميه ستكون اكثر شده عن المواسم
الماضيه وذلك نتيجه انخفاض نشاط فايروس
الانفلونزا في العامين الماضيين بنى
مواجهه السعوديه لجائكم
موسم فايروس الانفلونزا ياتي كل عام
ويتجدد الموسم في مثل هذه التوقيتات
تقريبا من كل عام الا ان هذا العام هنالك
امر مختلف
لماذا الاختلاف لماذا موسم الانفلونزا هذا
العالم هذا العام مختلف العالم يشهد فيه
موجات متفاوته من الاعداد والاصابات
ولكنها بشكل عام قد تكون اعلى من المواسم
السابقه
السبب في ذلك ياتي لان السنتين الاخيرتين
الماضيتين كانت النشاط او كان نشاط هذا
الفايروس
منخفضا فبالتالي كانت انتشاره بين الافراد
المجتمع وانتقاله في ما بينهم اقل كذلك
كان اقبال الناس واخذهم على لقاحات همم
في الوينزه ليست كالمعتاد طبعا كانت
تتزامن مع مواجهه النجاح اذكرونه بعده
وقائيه مهمه جدا ساهمت ولله الحمد في ان
تجاوز هذه الجائحه ونصل فيها الى هذه
المراحل بامان الله الحمد ولكن النشاط
والعوده فايروس الانفلونزا هذا العام مهم
جدا انه مواجهه ايضا بطرق وقائيه تجعلنا
باذن الله في ماء منه
في الواقع فيروس كورونا الحمد لله رب
العالمين الامور في مرحله السيطره وتحكم
ممتازه ومتميزه تاتي ثمار جهود جباره
بدلها ومجتمع واعي جدا وخاصه في قضيه اخذ
اللقاحات ومستوى المناعه الذي وصل اليه
مجتمعنا اليوم ولله الحمد
وهذا الامر جعل من الجارحه في مرحله تحكم
وسيطر على الله الحمد
معنى مجد الدكتور نزار الامراض المعديه
دكتور نزار مرحبا بك معي في نشرته الرابع
عندما يقول همم الدكتور محمد العبد العالي
او يتحدث عن الاسباب ما حدث في السنتين
الاخيرهتين هل هذا
يبرر ان تكون هناك حاله كثيره في العنايات
المركزه يمكن ان تصل كذلك يعني الى الى
حاله قاتله يعني
حقيقه نبغى ناكد على انه الانفلونزا عاده
في العالم قبل جائحه كورونا كانت تؤدي الى
وفيات في العالم
بمئات الالوف مما نتخيل نظرت هم كثير منهم
من كبار السن او من الاشخاص اللي عندهم
عده امراض
ولكن الان ايش اللي فرج العامين الماضيين
بيفرج اننا احنا كنا في بيوتنا كان عندنا
كمامات كنا ناخذ التطعيم حقه ما كان في
انفلونزا انت زي ما حضراتكم كل المشاهدين
يعرفوا انه الانفلونزا يحتاج التطعيم
يجددوا كل سنه فبالتالي الاجسام المضاده
حقنا تخف مع مرور الايام اللي ما تيجي
السنه اللي بعدها تحتاج انك بس تتخيل لان
سنتين ما في اجسام مضاده كثير وتعرف في
المجتمع على الانفلونزا ففي ناس الان
جاءتهم من انفلونزا يقولوا لك جدا شديده
والله ما تصدق لما جاءتني شديده لدرجه اني
ماني قادر اتحرك من البيت في ناس في
العنايات المركزه طيب هذا كله ناتج من ايش
ما في منا زي السابق ما في تعرض كثير كان
الانفلونزا فالان جايه في العالم هجمات
كثيره الناس بيقول لك لما تجيني
الانفلونزا بتهدني في البيت
ناخذ التطعيم علشان التطعيم قبل التطعيم
لا لا في ناس في ناس ذهبوا الى اكثر من
ذلك في الاسباب يعني بعد مراكز الخبراء او
الدراسات الطبيه الدكتور قالت بانهم
اكتشفوا ان جينات هذه الانفلونزا الموسميه
هي قريبه او ربما منقوله من سلاله جين
الانفلونزا الاسبانيه اللي كانت في 1918
صحيح
اشد من اي وقت وانا بتكلم من شخص من
المجتمع بيشوف كثير من الحالات اللي عايشه
في ما بيننا اما في عنايه مركزه لا سمح
الله حالات ما كنا نتوقع انه نشوف قد كده
انفلونزا في عنايه مركزه والناس نفسهم
اللي في المجتمع يقول لك والله ماني قادر
حتى اروح الدوام من قوه الانفلونزا اللي
جاتك نظرا لانه احنا بتجيء لنا سلاله
شديده وكمان الاجسام المضاده حقنا اقل
فبالتالي نحتاج ان ندعم مناعتنا بالمجتمع
الواعي اللي زي ايام الفراعنه ما كان اننا
ناخذ التطعيم علشان هذا اثبت فعاليه انه
يقلل المضاعفات والدخول لا سمح الله
للتطعيم احنا عندنا انفلونزا الموسميه
وعندنا نزلت برد عاديه لبعض يقول انها
نزلت برد عاديه وعندنا الفايروس المخلوي
التنفسي كمان انا قرات عن هذا الموضوع
فبالتالي انا كيف اتعامل او كيف تفرق
بينها يعني متى انا اكتشف انه هذه
انفلونزا موسميه او نزلت برد عاديه وهل
تفرق المساله في التعامل مع الاثنين
والله سؤال جدا رائع بكل بساطه الناس
يسموا كل شيء يسبب احتقان في الانف والالم
في الحلق او سخونه او ايسموهم في المنزل
لكن حقيقه كثير من الفيروسات حتى تعرف كان
دائما يواجهك اطباء يقول لك والله انا اخط
تطعيم الانفلونزا والله ولا فاد ما زال
جاتني انفلونزا هي هديه لما جاتك انفلونزا
جاتك الفيروسات الثانيه احنا دائما نقول
انه في فيروسات تيجي
للانف تبحث الصوت بس ما تنزل الصدر ما
تسبب لك كتمه ما تسبب لك انك تدخل العنايه
هذه اللي حضرتك كنت تقول عليها هذا نوع من
انواع الفيروسات التنفسيه لكن انفلونزا من
يعني من اشد الفيروسات اللي ممكن تصيب
الجهاز العلوي والجهاز السفلي فسبب التهاب
في الرئه ضيق في النفس هذه انفلونزا لما
يسوي لها التحليل حق الكسيري يقوم يقول لك
هذه انفلونزا الف وانفلونزا فاكر انفلونزا
الخنازير وغيرها انفلونزا الطيور هذه
حقيقه انفلونزا
وهذا اشد ما فيها ان هي تنزل الصدر تسوي
التهاب في الرئه لما يسوي اشياء
يدخلوا العنايه احيانا الناس يقول لك
والله ما هم قادرين يتنفسه
هذه تفرق عن بقيه الفيروسات اللي هي يوجعك
حلقك ينسد انفك بالتالي انا المثل المفروض
اروح للطبيب
احسنت
ضيق النفس ثم ضيق النفس ثم ضيق النفس
ثانيا عدم القدره على انك تاكل وتشربي لك
يجي لك جفاف في يهبط الضغط كده ارتفاع في
درجه الحراره هبوط في الضغط مو الخوف من
ارتفاع درجه الحراره الخوف وارتفاع
الحراره انخفاض الضغط هذا اللي لازم تروح
المستشفى ويلقى النفس او ارتفاع في
الحراره انخفاض الضغط
هل ممكن نقول انه الانفلونزا الموسميه
ممكن تكون سلاله قاتله او اخطر من كورونا
وهل يمكن انه يصاب الانسان في وقت واحد
بينفلونزا الموسميه
وبكرونا
وبالمخلوي التنفسيه هل ذلك ممكن هذا ممكن
في نفس الوقت لكنها شفنا حالات سبحان الله
من الاشخاص اللي دائما يتوتر كثير مناعتهم
يقولوا هم مناعه ضعيفه هي ما هي فعاله
شوفناها مصيبه بالكرامه وبعدها بشهره
واسبوعين يصيبوا الانفلونزا وبعدها اصيبوا
بالمخلوي اللي انت قلت عليه هذه حقيقه
تحصل مع بعض الاشخاص وعلشان كدا دائما
يقول خففوا من التوتر انتبه للكمامه انتبه
لغسيل يدك لكنهم التطعيم ثم التطعيم
ويتفاعل السهم المضاده هو اللي يخفف عليه
مثلا الحل هو التطعيم
الامراض الماضيه
بعد محادثاتنا اجراها مع ولي العهد
السعودي الى الامير محمد بن سلمان على
هامشي قيمه من الرياض اعلن الرئيس الصيني
شيء بينك بان الصين الدراجات السعوديه ضمن
قائمه المقصد الخارجيه للمجموعات السياحيه
الصينيه واكد الجانب ان السعوديه والصيني
بان التعاون في المجالس السياحي يعد امرا
مهما نظير المقاومات السياحيه التي يتمتع
بها البلدان ومن جانبها اشاره احصائياتنا
نشرتها وزاره السياحه السعوديه لان اعداد
السياحه الصينيين في السعوديه بلغها خلال
العام 2002 و2020 الف الجزائر في ظل
توقعاته بان يرتفع العدد خلال الفتره
المقبله
مشاهده القمه السعوديه الصينيه المنعقده
بالتزامن على هامشه قمم الرياض مع صين
توقيعه 20 اتفاقيه ومذكره التعاون بقيمه
تصل الى 110 مليارات ريال في مختلف
المجالات جاء من اهم هذه الاتفاقيات
الداعيه الى تطوير التبادل الثقافي بين
الصين والسعوديه توقيع مذكرات التعاون
تشمل تعليم اللغه الصينيه في الجامعات
والمدارس السعوديه فضلا عن تعزيز
التبادلات الثقافيه والشعبيه الاخرى بين
شعبين الجانبين
من رياض تنضم الي هاتفيا الدكتور عهود
الفارس وكاله وزاره التعليم للتعليم العام
اهلا دكتوره عهود يعني اولا بالاضافه الى
ما ذكرت ما ابرز ما تضمنت هذه المذكره
مذكره
التفاهم بين وزارتي التعليم السعوديه
والصيني
[موسيقى]
يا
مرحبا
تعليم في المملكه
[موسيقى]
في ما يخص تعليم اللغه الصينيه لطلب
السعوديين في جميع المراحل التعليم العام
ايضا همم فيها تبادل توفيق مقررات ومحتوى
تعليمي وما يتعلق بها من مواقع تعليميه
بصريه همم تنفيذ ايضا معلمين حسب الحاجه
لتعليم اللغه الصينيه في المدارس
التعليميه العامه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه وايضا تهنيئه
همم المهني والقدرات في تعليم اللغه
الصينيه وتعيينها وتاريخها
والتاريخ في ثقافاتها فقط يتم التوافق
عليها ايضا اقامه دورات تدريبيه انشطه
ثقافيه للمعلمين المتخصصين في اللغه
الصينيه وادا توفيق فرح دراسيه للطلبه
السعوديين الراغبين في استكمال ايضا تعلم
اللغه الصينيه بعد مرحله التعليم العام في
المؤسسات التعليم العاليه الصينيه واعطاء
الاولويه للطلبه الحاصلين على درجات
متقدمه في الاختبارات المعياريه
كانت قررت يعني ادخال تعليم اللغه الصينيه
في المناهج الان بعد المذكره
سابقا في عدد من المدارس
اه طبعا الان في تبادل همم يعني اشمل من
مجرد وجود وتدريس اللغه الصينيه زي ما
دخلنا تبادل همم في الخبرات التربويه
والتعليميه همم والمحتوى والمقابلات
وغيرها
اللغه الصينيه افتح الان لانه منهم لغات
العالميه الهامه يعني اقتصادي عالمي لذلك
وزاره التعليم اعتمدتها احد اللغات
المتاحه في التعليم العالي
بدا من السنه المبكر حتى نهايه الدراسه ثم
الجامعيه كمتطلب اساسي يعني فيها نجاح
رسوب وغيرها من غير اللغتين
لا يا مخلصات اختياريه في المرحله
الثانويه طبعا هناك خطبه لدراستها
وتطويرها وازاحتها على
يعني مراحل مختلفه
طبعا لانه النقط صينيه زي ما يعني ذكرنا
همم وفي حت من تقريبا سنتين لعدد من
الملابس والان ايضا ستتاح في نظام
المسارات للمرحله الثانويه
[موسيقى]
همم سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين على هذه
الزياره تعليق العلاقات
تعليمي اكثر في سنوات القادمه
في السعوديه يواصلوا معرض جدا للكتابه
2022 استقبال زواره في قبه السوبر دوم جده
يشهد المعرض الممتد فعالياته الى غايه
17 او 17 من شهر ديسمبر الجاري مشاركه
سماد دار نشر المحليه والدوريه تفضل لنا
عن اكثر من 100 فعاليه منوعه ما بين جلسات
حواريه واخرى شعريه بحضور ابرز المتحدثين
السعوديين والدوليين من مختلف المجلات
ايضا الرابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل مركز
الارصاد في السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدر المركز الوطني
للارصاد في السعوديه تنبيهات جديده حول
حاله الطقس المتوقعه على عدد من المناطق
في البلاد التوقعات المعلن عنها شملت حاله
من الامطار الغزيره والسحب الرعديه
بالاضافه الى تجنن في الرؤيه على مناطق
مكه المكرمه وعسير وجزان والباحه والجوف
والحدود الشماليه في السياقه اصدر مركز
الارصاد ايضا انذارا لسكان منطقه الرياض
حول مدى استمرار الامطار من حاله متوسطه
الى غزيره واتربه
يحتوي قسم الاحافير في هيئه المساحه
الجيولوجيه او [__] اكتشافات النثريه
مذهله ويعمل خبراء الجيولوجيون السعوديون
في هذا القسم على التنقيب عن الاحافير
ودراستها ما يسهم في دعم وتعزيز الجهود
البحريه العلميه كما يتم عمل نماذج الطبط
لاصل من الاحافير الاصليه وعرضها في
المتاحف المحليه والعالميه
يتجاوز عمره هذه القطاع 600 الف سنه وهي
واحده من نوادر الاحافير المكتشفه هنا حيث
يعمل قسم الاحافير بهيئه المساحه
الجيولوجيه على البحث والتنقيب ودراسه
الاحافير بانواعها في السعوديه
في هذه المنطقه عباره عن خيل تم اكتشاف
80% من هذا الفيل طبعا بعد استخراج همم
العينات
وجلب اهل المعمل كما دراستها نظفنا
ورممناه وعملنا قوالب جبسيه قوالب طبقه
الاصل لهذه العيالات تسهم هذه الاكتشافات
وفي دعمه وتعزيز الجهود البحثيه والعلميه
التي تستند في الدراساتها على ما تحققه
فرق البحث والتنقيب هنا
حيث يعمل خبراء جيولوجيون سعوديون في هذا
القسم منذ تاسيسه قبل 17 عاما
هي كانت كانت عايشه قبل مائه الالوف الى
100 ملايين من السنين الكائنات هذه ممكن
تكون بحريه او بريه الحافير ممكن تكون
عظام او اصداف او حتى جذوع اشجار
دور القسم دور القسم الاحافير نهايه
المساحه الجيولوجيه انه يبرز العينات
المميزه منها طبعا عن طريق الاكتشاف عن
طريق التدعيم عن طريق
نشر العلمي من همه هذه الاكتشافات عندنا
سعدان الحجاز وعندنا اصبع اليد انسان
بدائي بالاضافه الى في النفوذ اتصل
الاعمار هذه الاكتشافات الى 39 او 29
مليون سنه يحدده هذا الفريق اعمار
الاحافير المكتشفه بالاضافه الى اعمار
الصخور الحاويه لها كما يقوم هذا القسم
بعمل نماذج الاصلي من الاحافير الاصليه
لغرض دراستها وعرضها في المتاحف المحليه
والعالميه من جده عبد الواحد الحميد
العربيه
الموجز الرياضيه الان مع الزميل عبد الله
الدرويش
[موسيقى]
شكرا خالد حياكم الله مشاهدينا الى الموجز
الرياضي حسمت ركلات الترجيح رابعه مباراه
في الادوار الاقصائيه من نسخه الحاليه
للمونديال ونقلت الى الارجنتين الى نصف
النهائي على حسابه لواء الكره اللاتينيه
وسارت هي المباراه سلبيه النتيجه حتى مرر
ليونيل ميسي تمريره ساحره عند الدقيقه
الخامسه والثلاثين وضعها في المرمى بنجاح
انهاويل قبل ان يسجل ميسي هدفه الرابع في
البطوله من ركله جزاء عند الدقيقه الثالثه
وال70 وفيما اظن الجميع ان اللقاء انتهى
نجح البديل في جورج في تسجيل ثنائيه في
الدقائق الرابعه والثمانين والحاديه عشره
من الوقت بدل الضائع يتجه الفريقان الى
شوطين اضافيه ان لم يشهد تسجيل اي هدفه او
في ركلات الترجيح الحارس الارجنتينيز
ادى لي ركبتين وخدها منتخب بلاده باربع
ركلات لثلاث وستواجه الارجنتين في نصف
النهائي المنتخب الكرواتي
[تصفيق]
واكدت كرواتيا قبلها تخصصها بالمباريات
الاقصائيه واخرجت البرازيل من ربع النهائي
متجهه الى المربع الذهبي للبطوله بعد
فوزها بركلات الترجيح انتهاء الوقت الاصلي
والاضافي بالتعادل بهدف لكل فريق وانتهى
الشوطان الاصليان بالتعادل السلبي دون
اهداف ليلجا المنتخبان الى الوقتين
الاضافيين وفيه تقدم المنتخب البرازيلي
اولا عبر نيمار في الدقيقه والخامسه
ليعادل رقم الاسطوره بسبعه 77 هدفه قبل ان
يعادل برونو بيتكوبيتشر نتيجه في الدقيقه
السابعه عشر بعد المئه واحتكما بعد هائل
الى ركلات الترجيح التي ابتسمت للكروات
باربع ركلات
الاثنتين
[تصفيق]
المتعه والاثاره المصاحبه لمشوار المنتخب
المغربي تتواصل اليوم بمواجهه المنتخب
البرتغالي على ملعب الثمامه اسود الاطلس
وبعد الايطاحه باسبانيا في ثمن النهائي
يرغبون في كتابه التاريخ حيث سيصبح اول
منتخب عربي وافريقيا يفصل لنصف نهائي
العرس العالمي في حال تجاوز البرتغال
كتيبه المدرب وليد الركراني تعاني من بعض
الاصابات خاصه بعد المباراه الكبيره امام
المنتخب الاسباني وتحوم الشكوك حول مشاركه
فعلا
يسعى المغرب ان يكتب التاريخ في كاس
العالم حال فوزي بملعب الثمامه سيكون اول
منتخب افريقي يصلوا للمربع الذهبي بعد ما
اصبح بالفعل اول منتخب عربي يتاهل لدور
الثمانيه
اسود الاطلس يواجهون البرتغالي المره
الثالثه في كاس العالم المره الاولى كانت
عام 86 في المكسيك انتهت بفوز المغربي
بثلاثه اهداف مقابل هدف التقي من جديد هذه
المره في روسيا 2018 وهدف من رونالدو قاد
البرتغاليين للفوز
ويعتبر المنتخب المغربي الاقل استقبال
للاهداف بين المنتخبات المتاهله الى ربع
النهائي اذا اهتز شباكو ياسين بن مره
واحده وكانت بانيران الصديق من نايف اكرد
امام كندا
البرتغال انا فخور بمنتخب المغرب الاول
عربيا في الوصول لهذه المرحله كما ان كافه
الجماهير العربيه تدعمنا لنصنع التاريخ
سويا
لايقاف خطوره المنتخب البرتغالي التحدي
سيكون صعبا فلديهم لاعبون كبار وكم مدرب
للمغرب اتمنى ان لا يشارك كريستيانو
رونالدو اساسيا فهو احد افضل اللاعبين في
التاريخ
اغنيه
رونالدو
استخدامه في الشوط الثاني لانني توقعت
الصعوبه المواجهه امام سويسرا
على هذه المواجهه المرتقبه ينضم الينا من
العاصمه القطريه الدوحه من امام ملعب
لوسيل فهد الشهري وايضا معانا من الرباط
زميلنا ومراسلنا محمود المبارك
فهد اولا كيف هي الاجواء في الدوحه قبل
هذه المواجهه مواجهه ايضا اخرى في سطر
كتابه التاريخ للمنتخب المغربي امام
البرتغال
نعم عبدالله اليوم في استاد الثمامه
بالدوحه المنتخب المغربي يحاول ليطرز
اللوحه الجميله اللي رسمها امام اسبانيا
برواز اجمل ان شاء الله والتاهل للدور
القادم من هذه البطوله من كاس العالم طبعا
مشوار كل خطوه اصعب من الثاني عبد الله
كان الله بيعون اللعيبه في المنتخب
المغربي مدربهم يتخلص من اسبانيا يقابله
اليوم البرتغال مشوار صعب مشوار صعب مشوار
صعب همم ولكن ان شاء الله
هيكون نصر همم همم للفريق المغربي بس
للامه العربيه ان شاء الله واحنا نتمنى
الخير ان شاء الله مستعيدين اليومين
الماضيه كثير كثير سايبين احنا جينا من
همم
كل همم نواحي العالم انا جئت امريكا الاخ
من المغرب في صاحبنا من فرنسا علشان نشوف
هذا الماتش سعيدين قصير للمنتخب المغربي
اليوم والله احنا ما عندنا ثقه كامله وزيد
الحمد لله وان شاء الله جايين بعزيمه انا
نربحه
نفرحوش المغربي العربي
كل المتابعين العرب عبد الله احنا الان
بالجوار هذا الطريق المؤدي زي هيك كما
تشاهد انا اعتقد انه نسبه 50% من اللي
تشاهده ام عبد الله الان لا يملكوا تذاكر
هم يبعثهم بالمواقع يبحثون على امل اعاده
بيع التذاكر لمن لم يدخل الدوحه العدد
كبير عبد الله
الدرس سيكون بكامله للاحمر والاخضر
المغربي طبعا لان الفريق الثاني ايضا
المنتخب البرتغالي احمر واخضر لكن قلوبنا
من المغرب للحماس متعدد عبد الله الجميع
بانتظار بدايه المباراه وان شاء الله
التاهل المنتخب المغربي احنا راح نكون
معكم في النشرات القادمه الجمهور يحضر
بكثافه كما تشاهد ايضا الطريق الى الاخر
هنا جمهور كبير عبد الله
بانتظار بدايه المباراه فهد الشهري
مراسلنا من الدوحه شكرا جزيلا لك نتجه الى
الرباط محمود مبارك يعني في كل لحظه تقترب
منها المباراه تكون الاعصاب اكثر يعني همم
شده كيف كيف هي الاجواء من حولك كيف
يستعدادات ايضا المغاربه والمغرب لهذه
المباراه التاريخيه الاخرى
نعم عبد الله اليوم هو البحث كذلك عن رسم
ذلك السطر بعد اخراج اسبانيا الامال بعد
كل مباراه والتوقعات والاحلام يرتفع سقفها
اليوم الشارع المغربي المدن المغربيه كلها
تتمنى نفس سيناريو مباراه اسبانيا استدراج
واحد من عمالقه اوروبا وبعدها اخراجه
بعيدا عن كاس العالم مباراه
الجار البرتغال جار اسبانيا نفس الطموحات
نفس الامان ومعي للحديث اكثر همم المدرب
همم علي مصباح علي مصباح يعني اليوم
المنتخب المغربي المنتخب المغربي اليوم
المنتخب المغربي اخرج منتخب اسبانيا احداث
ثوابت في القاره الاوروبيه والعالميه
اليوم كذلك
بعد اقل من ساعه ونصف مباره كبيره امام
البرتغالي كمواطن كمدرب كيف هو الاحساس
اااه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم همم اولا
الاحساس هو احساس ايجابي لان المنتخب
المغربي اليوم هو في عتيقه انه يصنع
التاريخ
والموجود في كاس العالم من اجل
العقليه اتجاه
المنتخبات العربيه همم في الكاس العالم
واليوم ان شاء الله كما قدرناه همم
المنتخب الكرواتي ب همم نجومي والمنتخب
بلجيكي بوجومه وباسباني لماذا همم
خطوه اخرى اوكي ما قال الوالده الركراكي
كل مقابله هي مقابله نهائيا بالنسبه
للمجموعه النخبه الوطنيه اليوم ان شاء
الله همم
بالروح
الوطني وبالعزيمه وبالاراده وتحت
اننا نشرف الكره العربيه والكره الافريقيه
فسيكون ان شاء الله الفوز لا محل لنا ان
شاء الله ولو بفارق هدف واحد ان شاء الله
جميل يعني اليوم في غياب مدافعين اساسيين
في القطعه الاساسيه للمنتخب المغربي لو
انت محل وليد الركراكي
اخي محمود اي منتخب او اي فريق يشارك في
العالم ضروري ان يكون عنده بغا يمشي بعيد
همم في المشاركه همم في التصفيات او في
الاقصائيات ضروري يكون عنده دكه او دكه
البدلاء الاحتياط لان الاحتياط ليش احنا
الفراق اللي كتفوز بكاس العالم كي يكون
عندها الاحتياط همم لاعبين افضل من خيره
اللاعبين الموجودين داخل ركعه الملعب اللي
كاتدخل الاضافه وكانت تكون نقطه ايجابيه
همم
سعيده للمغرب شكرا
امال المنتخبان الفرنسي والانجليزي ايضا
يا سيلتقيان الليله للمره الاولى بدوري
خروج المغلوب في نهائيات كاس العالم بعد
ما التقي يا سابقا مرتين بدوري المجموعات
في موندياله 66 و82 وكانت الغلبه
للانجليزي المنتخب الفرنسي حامل لقب
النسخه الاخيره بقياده مدربه ديشان يسعر
الحفاظ على لقبه رغم الاصابات التي ضربت
صفوفه قبل اثناء البطوله بينما يسعى منتخب
الاسود الثلاثه لبلوغ المربع الذهبي للمره
الثانيه على التوالي والرابعه في تاريخه
والتي قد تفتح له ابواب التتويج باللقب
الثاني في تاريخه والاول منذ عام 66
نهايه الرياضي يعود الان الى خالد تفضل
[موسيقى]
شكرا عبدالله نبقى ايضا في نفس الاجواء
اجواء كاس العالم التي تسبق المباراه
المهمه اليوم بين منتخب المغرب والبرتغال
نذهب الان الى الدوا خايله منفد العربيه
من كليت وزاري مرحبا ليث مساء الخير
يمكننا التوتر والقلق كان سيد الموقف
الصوره من من المغرب مع مراسلنا من هنا
لكن كده الصوره عندك مختلفه خلينا نشوف
الاجواء
نعم خالد من سوق واقف من مشيرب وصلنا قبل
قليل الى محيط ملعب الثمامه هنا في الدوحه
التي ستقام على ارضها المباراه بين المغرب
والبرتغال ولكن يا محاسن الصدف صديق مغربي
يعمل في الرباط والتقيت فيه اكثر من مره
واذا يصرخ باسمه هنا وهو طبعا من مشجعين
الرياضه امين فارس هو من من الذي يحضر
المباريات المغربيه حتى لو بموسكو بتذكر
كنت موجود شو بتتوقع النتيجه اليوم كيف
شايف الاجواء انا اول حاجه احنا فخورين
باللي عملوا المنتخب المغربي مثل العرب
ومثل افريقيا احسن تمثيل
الحمد لله فرحه كبيره من الجميع المملكه
انت على الدوله انا وصلت امبارح بالليل
انا كنت في مباريات دور اول ورجعت
المباراه الربع وان شاء الله لو فوزنا
هابقى نصف النهائي والنهائي ان شاء الله
هذا ما يحصل كثيرا خالدا الكثير من الشباب
المغاربه لاحظت انهم ياتون الى الدوحه
للمباراه قبل قبل يوم من المباراه ثم
يعودون اما الى المغرب او بلدان مجاوره
لزياره البلدان المجاوره وهو يعودون يوم
يوم الملعب قبل يوم من المباراه
وهذا جزء مهم طبعا المشجعون هم اللاعب 12
في المباراه او هذا واحد شاهدناه في
المباراه عندما كانت اقيمت بين نعم بين
اقيمت بين المغرب
واسبانيا وهذا طبعا كان هذا يعني عنصر
رئيسي وشاهدنا الكثير من الفنانين الذين
اتوا من المغرب العربيه قابلنا همم قبل
يومين الشاب خالد الذي اتى لتشجيع المنتخب
المغربي وهو كان في استاد وشاهدنا كذلك
جمال الدين نذكر في النشرات السابقه ويوجد
الكثير من المغاربه يعني هذا نوع الحماس
ليس فقط همم مغربي خالد شاهدنا كثير من
الذين ياتوا من البلدان العربيه من فنانين
وغيرهم وطبعا هلا امينه تركي تفوت على
الساده اكيد متاخر شكرا كثير شكرا نعم هذه
الاجواء ومن هنا ينطلق الشباب من هذه
البوابه الى هذا الجسر الذي ياخذ ال ال
المشجعون الى همم الى النقطه الاخرى
للذهاب الى استاذ الثمامه ومن ثم يدخلون
هذا استاد
ساعه هذا السيد
44,000 شخص ولكن همم مع عندما كانت
المباراه بين المغرب واسبانيا اتسع على
44,000 شخص 672 لا ادري اليوم ولكن اشاهد
حشود اكثر من الوضع الطبيعي خالد فهذا قد
يكون يعني حافز كما قلنا قبل قليل فال-
همم تربح او يربح المنتخب المغربي
المباراه
الالوان الاحمر والاخضر هي التي تكسل مكان
وقد تكون احمر واخضر برتغاليه كذلك نعم
لان نفس اللون العلوي ولكن ههه
وشاهدنا بعض البرتغاليين
لما اسالك انا
لو بعرف يا خالد حرام عليك
المنتخب الاخر اذا كانت اثنين صفر وهذا ما
يتمنى الجميع
في هذه المباراه ايضا نتمنى لهم الفوز
وديما المغرب شكرا
مو فادي العربيه من الدوحه
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بالعنايه
تضرب عائلته
للحرس الثوري تلمحه لاعدام عشرات
المتظاهرين
متبادله وشراكه استراتيجيه شامله بين
الدول العربيه
صفحه السعوديه تقول الا لشاطر انفلونزا
الموسميه هذا العام اكوام ومن السنوات
الماضيه
والجماهير تترقب مواجهه اسود الاطلس مع
منتخب البرتغال
بالتوفيق للمنتخب المغربي الى اللقاء